i got a question for you because i know
i know you're musically inclined
yeah kind of you know you are you are
have you
have you considered doing like a musical
on broadway when broadway is
allowed to come back like is that
something that you would ever you know i
had an uh
a part that i've always been fascinated
with so much so that i wrote a simpsons
episode about it
years ago i was a music man and uh
susan strowman did a great revival of
the music man
i want to say about 15 20 years ago with
craig biarco who destroyed he was
absolutely pitch perfect and then he
left someone else came and then they
were looking for someone else
a third person uh to play the part of
the music man
and um susan strowman uh contacted me
to discuss it with me and of course uh
i found out that i i couldn't do that in
the late night show at the same time so
i was kind of heartbroken
but well you know what you're in luck
because i think there is another revival
of the music man is there okay yes
hugh jackman is uh is doing that well
yes now of course
i i'm sorry but
i guess whose phone isn't going to ring
after this interview airs
my come on now come on people are going
to be like you could do it
well we got we locked in hugh jackman
did you see conan last night he was
talking to andrew reynolds yeah
jackman
get rid of him get that [ __ ] up our shoe
let's get o'brien
uh i gotta tell you that that monorail
episode of the simpsons is one of my
favorites oh thank you absolutely it was
my love letter to the broadway show i've
always wanted to be in so
someday in dinner theater and i'll make
you i'll make you be there